CALL.
BUT A QUICK REMINDER YOU HAVE
THE RIGHT TO REMAIN SILENT.
JOINING WITH US THE REACTION,
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT SEBASTIAN GORKA.
AND LARRY ELDER, BOTH OF YOU
ARE OF LAUGHING.
LARRY IS LAUGHING HARDER SO WE
WILL GO TO HIM FIRST.
LARRY?
>> WELL, SEAN, IF YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS TOWN YOU
KNOW THAT THEY WILL EMBRACE
JAMES COMEY LIKE NOBODY'S
BUSINESS.
I'M SURPRISED THEY HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT ACTION FIGURE OR
REALITY SHOW OR SOMETHING LIKE
AT HOMEY WITH COMEY.
HE WILL BE EMBRACED.
>> Sean: ACTION FIGURE!
JAMES COMEY.
HOW TO RIG AN INVESTIGATION BY
JAMES COMEY?
THAT IS ANOTHER GOOD ONE.
>> YOU REMEMBER THE MOVIE
"HURRICANE" THAT CELEBRATED
THE LIFE OF A MAN WHO MURDERED
THREE PEOPLE?
NO QUESTION HE MURDERED THREE
PEOPLE.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE MOVIE
DONE WITH DRAN RATHER CALLED
"TRUTH" DONE WITH ROBERT
REDFORD CALLED "TRUTH" THAT
CELEBRATED THE LIE THAT RATHER
PUSHED ARGUING THAT GEORGE W.
BUSH GOT PREFERRED TREATMENT
WITH THE TEXAS AIR NATIONAL
GUARD.
DON'T FORGET THE MOVIE WITH
JOE WILSON AND THE VALERIE
PLAME EVEN THOUGH SAID THEY
THAT HE LIED IN THE "STATE OF
THE UNION" SPEECH SO BELIEVE
ME THE TOWN IS GOING TO
EMBRACE JAMES COMEY.
THE QUESTION IS HOW MUCH MORE
WILL THEY EMBRACE MUELLER WHEN
HE WRITES HIS BOOK.
>> Sean: WE KNOW HE RELEASED
PRIVILEGE INFORMATION SO HE
COULD GET A SPECIAL COUNSEL
THAT TURNS OUT TO BE HIS BEST
FRIEND.
WE KNOW HE RIGGED THE
INFORMATION INTO HILLARY.
THAT EVIDENCE WAS SO
OVERWHELMING.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THE I.G.
REPORT.
WE ALSO KNOW HE WAS AWARE THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR THE PHONY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
THEY PRESENTED IT BEFORE A
FISA COURT.
AND THEY DIDN'T TELL THE FISA
COURT SOME KEY BIT OF
INFORMATION LIKE OH, HILLARY
PAID FOR THIS.
IT IS A POLITICAL DOCUMENT.
NOT ONLY IS IT NOT VERIFIED
IT'S FULL OF LIES.
BUT THEY GOT THE FISA WARRANT
FOUR TIMES THAT WAY.
>> LARRY IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THE CESSPOOL THAT IS HOLLYWOOD
WILL EMBRACE THIS MAN
ABSOLUTELY.
BECAUSE HE IS A EGOTIST WITH
NO MORAL COMPASS JUST LIKE
HOLLYWOOD.
YOU HAVE TO LAUGH BECAUSE YOU
THINK THAT SOONER OR LATER
THEY WILL GET THE MESSAGE.
NOBODY IS GOING TO WATCH THEIR
FILMS.
WHEN YOU WATCH THE OSCARS,
THEY INSULT MOST OF AMERICA.
YOU KNOW, THEY COULD TURN IT
AROUND.
THEY COULD TURN IT AROUND AND
SAY OKAY, WE WILL DO A MOVIE
ABOUT HOW BENT COPS GOT AN
ILLEGAL WARRANT TO SPY ON
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
WE ARE GOING TO DO A
DOCUMENTARY STYLE DRAWMA PIECE
ABOUT A WOMAN -- DRAMA PIECE
ABOUT A WOMAN WHO RAN FOR
PRESIDENT AND ILLEGAL PUT 108
TOP SECRET E-MAILS ON HER
SERVER.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T MAKE IT
UP.
>> PEOPLE WOULD GO AND SEE
THOSE MOVIES.
PEOPLE WOULD GO BACK TO
HOLLYWOOD.
>> LET ME PLAY BOTH OF YOU.
I DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME.
THIS IS CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN
GIVING A SPEECH IN MIAMI
TUESDAY.
>> WHEN A GUY WHO ENDED UP
BECOMING OUR NATIONAL LEADER
SAID I CAN GRAB A WOMAN
ANYWHERE AND SHE LIKES IT AND
THEN SAID I MADE A -- I DIDN'T
MAKE A MISTAKE.
BUT ASKED ME WOULD I LIKE TO
DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN?
NO.
IF WE WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL I'D
TAKE HIM BEHIND THE GYM AND
BEAT THE HELL OUT OF HIM.
>> Sean: BIG, TOUGH, CRAZY
UNCLE JOE.
IMAGINE, AND I WOULD NEVER SAY
THIS AND I TRAINED PRETTY HARD
M.M.A. FIVE DAYS A WEEK.
WHAT IF I SAY, WHICH I NEVER
SAW, CRAZY UNCLE JOE, COME
MEET ME IN THE OCTAGON.
WHAT WOULD THE REACTION BE,
LARRY ELDER?
>> THERE IS A BOOK CALLED NO
ONE LEFT ALIVE.
HE WRITES FOR "NATION
MAGAZINE."
HE SAID THERE WERE THREE
PLAUSIBLE ALLEGATION OF RAPE
AGAINST BILL CLINTON AND
NOBODY CARED ABOUT THE BOOK.
THERE WAS ANOTHER BOOK CALLED
"CONFIDENCE" WHO IS A PULITZER
PRIZE WINNER THAT CAME OUT AND
SAID THE SEXISM IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, THIS IS A PRIVATE
SECTOR.
WE COULD BRING IT UP ON THE
HOUSE STYLE WORKPLACE
VIOLATION.
NOBODY CARES.
THIS BOOK COMES OUT, OH, MY
GOODNESS.
LET'S DO A MOVIE.
>> Sean: LAST WORD.
>> JOE BIDEN.
>> Sean: CRAZY UNCLE JOE.
>> THE MAN WHO GOT EVERY ISSUE
WRONG FOR 30 YEARS.
THAT IS ALL I'LL SAY ABOUT
HIM.
>> Sean: YOU CAN'T WORK AT A
7-ELEVEN UNLESS YOU HAVE A
SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
HE IS BRIGHT, HE IS